président Hassan vous avez la parole
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre des enfants des femmes frappées
par les bombes jetés sur les routes par
million des centaines de milliers de
civils et de soldats tués voilà le
terrible bilan de la folie meurtrière
déclenchée voici près d'un an par le
sinistre Poutine qui a fait le choix
irresponsable d'envahir l'Ukraine le
choix du sang et des larmes violant les
règles du droit international mettez un
péril la sécurité en euros relançant une
désastreuse course aux armements ce
constat implacable nous rappelle une
évidence trop peu évoquée en ces heures
de déchaînement de violence notre seul
horizon doit être celui de la paix oui
la paix sans que cette exigence ne
puisse être perçue comme un signe de
capitulation car il y a bien un
agresseur il est clairement désigné et
un pays en état légitime défense que
nous soutenons sans ambiguïté en
important les moyens de se défendre
pleinement c'est dans ce cadre là que
doit continuer de s'inscrire notre
engagement militaire avec la volonté de
ne pas devenir cobelligérant et de ne
pas contribuer à une dangereuse escalade
guerrière par la livraison d'arme
lourdes offensive qui serait bien plus
qu'un simple enrichissement du
vocabulaire nous avons aussi un devoir
tout aussi important celui de porter
assistance à une population courageuse
plongée dans le tumulte et le chaos
c'est ce que nous faisons dans nos
communes depuis le début du conflit
grâce à l'action des élus et des
bénévoles à la générosité des familles
d'accueil de réfugiés je veux saluer ici
ce mouvement fraternel cette manne
tendue à nos amis Ukrainiens représentés
aujourd'hui par le président de son
Assemblée nationale ce soutien passe
aussi par la recherche d'une solution
diplomatique le plus la plus rapide
possible comme le les mouvements
pacifistes de l'Ukraine et de la Russie
ouvrir les chemins de la paix à
l'inverse d'une escalade guerrière dans
laquelle aucune limite ne serait plus
posée dans l'utilisation des armes les
plus destructrices n'oublions jamais
chers collègues les 80 millions de morts
des deux guerres mondiales du siècle
passé c'est la raison pour laquelle il
nous semble urgent de remettre le nu au
centre des discussions membres
permanents du Conseil des sécurités de
l'ONU la France un rôle important à
jouer dans ce cadre-là madame la
Première ministre La France est-Elle
prête à engagé des moyens diplomatiques
plus importants auprès de l'ONU pour
parvenir à un cas de sécurité collectif
durable et acceptable par toutes les
parties impliquées êtes-vous prête aussi
à répondre favorablement à la demande
que j'ai formulée avec mon collègue
Fabien Roussel au nom de groupe de la
Gauche de brouhantés républicaines pour
que je sois organisé ici même un débat
sur la position de la France concernant
la livraison d'armes
[Applaudissements]